we tried for a long time to get pregnant
and really put the to us to hell okay
we're gonna have a family are you sure
you still want to be a surrogate yes I
am look at her eyes she means it we do
this first one make sure that you and I
are comfortable we're down to our last
viable embryo the baby is your business
home I'm gonna be a father
mr. Mitchell is gonna be taken in in
charge of domestic battery I don't have
another place to stay this your doing
Anna we'd like you to stay here with us
if you ever come near Anna again what's
your handle I love that dress
okay you can admit it it's beautiful I
told Laura she's lucky to have you
that must be nice living up in that make
beautiful houses
is that the dress you gave her no that's
not don't be afraid of me John you're
already inside of me you can do anything
you want to me so we're gonna happen
when you're around me my whole body
reacts
what do you mind
Joe you need to be nicer to me this is
my baby I will leave
that is our baby she cannot leave when
does it become a kidnapping never when
she gives birth it is her child until
she relinquishes that right you're gonna
get more money and in the eyes of the
law since it's inside of you it belongs
to us she's dangerous Jonas can kill you
a baby today to bring my baby
Lenna Familia Vienna Durango sensor than
yours I love this we have a talk
important for my name Ivan and Buddha
masala provides the Army fighters to
talk warmth Alagna glute and sky